what if the kraken were real  although this creature is said to be a  myth it also doesn't have any bones so  there's no way for it to have any  fossils and paleontologists would have  no way of discovering it  so could this thing be real  well if it does exist people out at sea  would have to be worried about the crack  and taking down their ships ocean  traveling and fishing would look very  different if the kraken was terrorizing  our seas certain cultures and  civilizations might not have discovered  new lands at least not until air travel  was invented  any myths or rumors you've heard about  the kraken in the past are most likely  attributed to their very real and very  terrifying squid cousins but humans have  only explored five percent of the  world's oceans so who knows what  mysteries are down there  maybe the kraken does exist  so have you ever asked yourself